take a moment and picture your favorite
childhood bicycle what did it look like
what color was it you have one of those
weird banana seats that used to be so
popular and perhaps you're the creative
type with cards and your spokes and
streamers coming from your handlebar my
bike was a bright red Schwinn with a
cushy black seat and he's sweet pegs on
my front wheel I rode my bike everywhere
as a child to school to my friends house
to the pool I even ordered on an
ill-fated attempt to run away from home
you see his children without a car or
driver's license it is the bike that
provides us with the ultimate sense of
freedom and independence now think back
to your most recent interaction with a
bike when was it what were you doing
perhaps your community campus today on a
bike or maybe went for a ride on the
curvy roads of coastal California as
adults the bike provides us with a
different type of freedom freedom from
work free from stress cream from routine
the bike scratches our itch for
adventure and provides us with a brief
escape from reality I've been riding
bikes my entire life for a period of
time I even raced mountain bikes
professionally on the world cup circuit
it's easy for many of us to view the
bike through the lens of a child a
weekend warrior or maybe even a
professional but a few years ago I began
to wonder if there's something more to
the bike what if that freedom that a
bike provides is more impactful than
just the independence of a child or the
exercise an adult what if the bike could
inspire us to tackle some of the world's
most complex problems allow me to take
you on a bit of a journey it's july two
thousand nine in a tiny village in rural
Zambia balita a fifteen-year-old girl
who lives in the village wakes up before
dawn to feed her family's chickens
before school Boadicea meets daily to
chill all a basic school three miles
away over unmaintained
dirt roads balita unlike many of us
bleed it does not have access to a car
or a school bus so please has to make
this long walk on foot now let's think
about this for a second three miles on
foot every day each direction that's
like walking from this classroom to the
dutch goose twice a day barefoot on dirt
roads on the hottest day of the year in
Palo Alto I also don't think there's a
juicy hamburger and GSP foam at the end
of this road but seriously how good with
your school attendance be if you had to
walk that far to get to school I'll to
admit I don't think mine would be very
good on this particular day it takes
bleedin 90 minutes to get to school and
by the time she arrives she's late and
she's fatigued from the long commute
bleeding did not have time that morning
to complete her homework before school
so she quickly falls behind blue to
attend school only three days a week
their academic performance is low let me
ask you what you think would happen if
balita if we gave Lee to a bike fast
forward of 2011 in the same tiny village
in rural Zambia blida wakes up before
dawn the theater families chickens
before school we de then collects her
new bike but she recently received from
world bicycle relief a charity
organization that delivers purpose-built
bikes in places like Zambia the three
mile commute to school takes only 20
minutes on a bike so bleed arrives on
time prepared with energy to focus we
didn't attend school five days a week
and her academic performance is soaring
the bike has reinvigorated bleed as
energy towards life and she's now on
track to achieving her lifelong dream of
becoming a nurse you know Scientific
American once published a really great
study to determine which animal species
consumed the least energy to travel a
fixed distance point A to point B we're
talking efficiency of motion perhaps not
surprisingly the Condor its ability to
soar on its huge 10-foot wingspan ranked
number one
the human stroll across the finish line
an underwhelming third of the way down
the list turns out we're not designed
for speed or efficiency we are however
quite adept at overcoming our
deficiencies using our brains
researchers then reran the study
providing the human with a single tool
you got it a bike with the aid of a bike
the human Rose all the way to the top of
the list above the Condor is the most
efficient animal species on the planet
behold human creativity and the power of
the bicycle my friends the bike is an
incredibly powerful tool with the aid of
a bicycle a human can carry five times
as much weight and can travel four times
faster than a person on foot that trip
to the market that one's yielded 40
pounds of rice now yields 200 that
hour-and-a-half commute is now 20
minutes these statistics are staggering
staggering enough to be life-changing
for balita and others do not have access
to modern forms of transportation
studies have proven that in places like
Zambia a bike can increase academic
performance by sixty percent that's the
difference between GMAT score of 440 a
gmat score of 700 I don't think of the
Dean down here to tell you how
meaningful that is the bike has the
power to free people from poverty now
that is what I call freedom but not only
is the bike a really powerful tool it's
also a very simple tool two wheels
pedals handlebar and a seat connected by
a simple metal frame you can even take a
class here at Stanford where you learn
to build your very own bike from scratch
and the bike is old technology the bike
was invented in Germany in 1817 and much
of the original construction has remain
unchanged in the last 200 years look I
don't mean to suggest that the bike is
without its challenges we need to fix
flat tires and repair used bikes but if
we can overcome these small hurdles we
have such an incredible tool the bike is
powerful and yet it's simple
the bike has the ability to meaningfully
improve huge global problems like
illiteracy poverty and hunger but basic
transportation is just is the bikes core
competency and basic inflation is only
one of thousands of big hairy problems
we face in our world today can we take
what we've learned from the bike and
apply it to these other issues as well I
think so you know here at Stanford we're
encouraged to tackle big problems and
change our world for the better while
inspiring this mandate is also daunting
I find myself wondering why am I more
qualified than the many brilliant minds
that came before me donated significant
financial resources to even begin I
don't know about you but I often feel
overwhelmed by the enormity of our
world's problems fixed poverty cure
cancer eradicate malaria I can feel my
anxiety levels rising already my
overwhelmed mind wants to give up before
I even begun the bike though has become
my source of inspiration when I'm
feeling overwhelmed by an impossibly
complicated task I think back to balita
an impact that a humble everyday bike
has had on her life I gained confidence
knowing that incremental solutions to
some of Zambia's worst problems don't
require a rocket scientist or a billion
dollars the bike is a great example of
how simple tool can have a profound
impact on our world maybe I am up to the
task and maybe you are too I'll leave
you with this sometimes we don't need
billion-dollar R&D budgets to tackle big
problems all we need is creativity and a
bit of perspective world bicycle relief
is changing the world through the power
of the bicycle what other everyday tools
are we overlooking simple sustainable
solutions exist for many of the world's
most complex problems in some cases a
meaningful solution may be parked in
your garage with a flat tire and a thin
coat of dust all you have to do is
reimagine its potential thank you